[Music]
welcome to the QuickStart tutorial for
Google Cloud V PC
on the V PC Network page select create V
PC network for name type in Auto -
network 1 under subnet creation mode
select automatic then click create the
auto network will now be created let's
create a custom Network create new
network by clicking on create V PC
network again under the name type custom
- network 1 click on the add subnet
button under name type subnet - us -
Central - 1 9 - select US central 1 as
the region in the IP address type
192.168.1.0 / 24 select add subnet
button again under name type subnet -
europe - west - 192
select Europe West 1 as the region and
type the IP address as 192.168.0 / 24
now select add subnet one more time
under name type subnet - Asia - East -
192
select Asia East 1 as the region and
typed the IP address as one ninety two
dot one sixty eight dot 7.0 / 24 select
create congratulations you've now
created a custom Network and an
automatic VPC Network
[Music]